con el vamos a actualizar la situación
en nicaragua en cuanto a los derechos
humanos y la prensa en ese país de
américa central porque los últimos días
el gobierno en el ortega en nicaragua
ordenó el cierre de otras 100 ong con lo
que se suman a las 958 son
organizaciones civiles sin fines de
lucro disueltas además al menos tres
medios de comunicación tradicionales de
ese país han suprimido o disminuido la
cantidad de temas políticos de su agenda
trasera amenazados por el ejecutivo con
cerrarlos definitivamente así lo
denunció la red de regional voces del
sur es algo más entonces arrestar a
israel el ebit es activista de derechos
humanos y también analista político
nicaragüense en el exilio gracias israel
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 la mañana de martes
le pregunto entonces la situación actual
de nicaragua en cuanto a las ong y en
cuanto a los derechos humanos
es insólito lo que está ocurriendo en
nicaragua la dictadura daniel ortega ha
ido desarrollando un plan en el cual no
solamente se ha tratado de instaurar al
frente sandinista como un partido único
sino también ha intentado invadir
absolutamente todas las esferas que
involucran al individuo ha eliminado a
la prensa libre ya indicamos no tenemos
periódico impreso
controlado las cámaras por ejemplo de la
el escocés de lo que es la cámara de la
empresa privada están en la cárcel y
ahora lo encierran las ongs se nota que
intenta un control total sobre lo que es
la organización ciudadana cerraron la
carne la lengua de la academia de
ciencias los
cómo ves la organización de las de las
de la madre teresa de calcuta
donde han expulsado a estas religiosas
como si fueran criminales
organizaciones de derechos humanos
organizaciones de feministas
organizaciones de defensa del medio
ambiente el estado lo quieres controlar
absolutamente todo y ahora en ese
control también pues esta situación con
la prensa que como bien ya lo estábamos
diciendo están denunciando entonces que
han sufrido algún tipo de presión y
amenazas por parte
del régimen de daniel ortega de
cerrarlos definitivamente no y por eso
tuvieron entonces que disminuir la
cantidad de información política un poco
como lo que pasó en venezuela tras estas
amenazas también de cierre en medios de
comunicación pues los medios decidieron
por no tener tanta información política
o en contra del gobierno en ese entonces
de del presidente hugo chávez
si el régimen de daniel ortega
no solamente amenaza a definitivamente
actuado de manera
muy decidido encontrar prensa libre y lo
que hace es que entra a esto a los
edificios los confisca algunos
periodistas de renombre han logrado huir
como es el caso de carlos fernando
chamorro otros están presos
es realmente impresionante lo que está
haciendo la dictadura y definitivamente
ha ido cruzando una serie de límites y
demostrando la ineficacia
de la los organismos internacionales
para aprender fenómenos como este y
también es tiene eficacia se ve
y tengo que denunciarlo hasta en la
iglesia católica porque hemos visto una
persecución en contra de líderes
religiosos en contra organizaciones
religiosas y seguimos notando un
silencio por parte del vaticano
ante esta escalada represiva en todos
los ámbitos de la vida ciudadana
nicaragüense israel también hablemos de
algo que usted después ha mencionado
ahora todos estos políticos que han sido
presos o perseguidos de alguna manera
por el por el ejecutivo de ortega cuál
es la situación actual de ellos y
también usted en el exilio cómo pueden
hacer para ayudarlos cómo están
trabajando ustedes para poder denunciar
todos estos hechos y cómo se enteran
nada más de lo que realmente pasa en su
país
como tenemos que recordar daniel ortega
decidió ante su inminente
derrota electoral simplemente meter a la
cárcel a siete precandidatos opositores
cualquiera que hubiera podido ganarle
unas elecciones medianamente justas y
ellos están presos desde hace más de un
año en condiciones violatorias de sus
derechos humanos todos han presentado y
han bajado más de 40 libras varios de
ellos situaciones de aislamiento sin
exceso al sol sin acceso a la lectura y
no hay comunicación no tiene acceso a la
defensa son juicios que se realizan
adentro de las cárceles
en el exilio se habla pues que hay casi
200.000 nicaragüenses que hemos tenido
que salir por situaciones políticas y
también por situaciones económicas
porque toda esta escalada represiva ha
tenido un impacto en la economía
pero lo que nos queda definitivamente es
hacer presión y yo hago un llamado a
todos los ciudadanos de él desde la
región que presiona a sus gobiernos para
que se tomen medidas más decididas en
contra del régimen de daniel ortega lo
que estamos sufriendo
es simplemente increíble es un escenario
distópico como creo que pocas veces se
ha visto en la historia de latinoamérica
entonces yo suplicó que se dé más y se
haga más consigues una situación que se
presione a los gobiernos porque la
situación es grave y ha cruzado
absolutamente todos los límites de lo
imaginable ahora israel ya nos quedaba
un minuto digamos para concluir nuestra
conversación pero le quería preguntar si
no pues no quería dejar de mencionarlo
creo que toda esta arremetida que ha
hecho en estos últimos días y estas
últimas semanas del gobierno ortega es
para como que tener algún tipo de más
presión en la población y logros digamos
con motivo del 20 de julio cuando se
celebra el 43 aniversario de la
revolución sandinista
definitivamente daniel ortega está
desarrollando un plan que lo que intenta
es monopolizar absolutamente todas las
extras del quehacer público viene
ahorita la celebración del 19 de julio
en donde él
es paradójicamente
celebra la caída de la dictadura de
somoza en la cual él fue parte de esa
lucha para ahora estar desde un trono en
una dictadura que es aún más ruidosa que
la de somos a una contradicción
histórica que todos pues lamentamos